Now that you know about polynomial time reductions, imagine that we had one problem in NP
such that every other problem that is also in NP could be reduced to it.
We would have vertex cover which could be reduced to that problem,
we would have independent set which could be reduced to that problem, and also clique, of course.
And any other problem in NP as well.
No matter how complicated that problem as long as it's NP that means
a non-deterministic RAM you can solve it in polynomial time--
there exist a polynomial time reduction to this ultimate problem.
And such a problem actually has a name, so if you could find a problem in NP
such that any other problem in NP is just as hard to solve or easier to solve,
then that problem is called NP complete because in a way it represents all of the problems in NP
because if it's a problem that any other problem can be reduced to, an NP complete problem
is basically capable of solving or representing all other problems that are contained in NP.
An NP complete problem is contained in NP and the important part here is
that really any other problem in NP can be reduced to it.
Not just vertex cover, not just independent set, not just clique
but any problem that lies in NP can be reduced to that problem.
Let's have a little quiz to familiarize yourself with the concept of NP completeness.
I have three statements here about NP complete problems
and I would like you to tell me which one of these is true.
There can be more than one.